[Music]
when I was a boy my brother would always
ask me which way you're gonna go
will you go the righteous I will you go
with it down it's a story about the part
I chose Kingston Jamaica King Fox
control streets in term it to get more
Cabrera with a mission deliver the goods
to Rico when it is done you let me know
yes I'm Alana London I had to do is
deliver Dakota Rico I'm I never liked
him first time so I'm on first time
trust me below with me
[Applause]
for years I haven't seen anybody be for
tacky
Dave for Dennis come here for change my
life
forget away from Kingston look at
yourself degree never left you just like
my daughter
no you're getting shot down like that
ancient history
[Music]
they are trouble masks ever deliver the
goods to Rico but frosty Rio Rico is a
liability me after deal understand
can't obvious nonsense our only
but I just gone back to Jamaica
sometimes America chooses on bar I sent
you to London so you wouldn't start a
war in Kingston
[Music]
you